ah we're just having a result the Press
Association has said that Kirsten has
been elected the next leader of the
Labour Party they have they have snapped
it somehow managing to get through the
Labor Party website problems and have
confirmed the Press Association
confirmed that case Dharma is the next
leader we wait for more details but that
means that case Dharma if it does appear
to be him Kirsten will be will face an
enormous job trying to change the
direction lobe party you mentioned the
general secretary Formby and other top
officials it's not directly in his gift
to force them to leave that is up to the
elected National Executive Committee
which until now has had a majority of
koban supporters on it the just hearing
via the Press Association and a little
bit more detailed from Jim pick out of
the Financial Times
Kirsten won the leadership on the first
round that means he got more than 50% of
the votes cast angela Rainer they said
to have won the deputy leadership on the
third round let's just talk about the
significance of an outright win for
Kirsten well we haven't seen that for
quite a long time not since Tony Blair I
don't think so we're just waiting for
confirmation it was on the first round
there is one source saying that that's
the case but we haven't seen the numbers
so we wait and see and but the new
global membership polling has definitely
suggested that Kirsten has done that now
that is important because it gives
secure Kira's I suspect she'll prefer to
be known a clear mandate for change